this is rapidly shutting down the
restaurant I've got some work to do and
I got to get out of there guys that
makes me feel sick I'm the owner and
this is my kitchen this is my place I
should be the one taking control of the
situation Chef Ramsey uncovered many
problems at mojito but for this
restaurant to ever work properly he has
to understand the issues between Marcelo
and he spends the morning with both
of them okay all I've seen so far is a
bossy angry little princess the
resturant suffering on the back of both
you constantly hurting each other he
does it to you you do it to him and it's
so sad and it's affecting everybody else
down the line it's embarrassing take me
back 7 years when you got
married we are together all time
everybody say you are the perfect couple
we decide to have a baby so we started
to to do fertilization process the IVF
and nothing happened I was putting
everything into it mhm and I was willing
to sacrifice and to do and go through
the treatment but it was no support from
him like while I was on the treatment
injecting myself he was out partying
with friends I was being left alone
that's when I'm like no not happening
you're not coming home to me at 7:00 in
the morning I'm your wife so that's when
everything started going wrong how did
the marriage break down go to Florida
for one year and a half in Miami did she
meet somebody else in Miami did she meet
another man in Miami yeah I took a trip
during the trip I decided till I was
going to leave him you're not making me
happy I'm not making you happy go your
way I'll go my way do you think it's
time that one of you says goodbye to the
business and give each other space I
think we'll be very
[Music]
healthy I want C off of this business
she don't have any idea of how run a
business she don't do nothing
how important is the business for you
it's everything for me the person that I
was married to the person doesn't exist
anymore he's
gone and I have to move
on and that's what I'm doing and I take
the loss of my marriage
mhm and I think that's the price that I
have to pay for my business so I'm
taking it on my business because that's
all I have
left
whatever it takes I'll go to the end
until I feel that there's nothing else
that I can
do I've got a plan I just I need to see
you like it was for and half five years
ago you know funny confident and no
bickering I'm committed okay thank you
come
here stand strong thank you this is a
serious ious world premere and the movie
is entitled PJ's the word on the street
oh gosh I don't have a good feeling
about this I'm scared to see what's
going to happen lights
please have you ever been to PJs PJs
I've been there quite often actually
when was the last visit to PJs 6 months
ago I boycotted it they never cooked the
stick right this is incredible the same
went on 6 months ago I saw last
night how was dinner atrocious pretty my
son's steak was hockey puck they
actually recognized two of the customers
that was on that tape and I said holy
I ordered salmon I got flounder
that's ridiculous how many people have
you told in the last 6 months not to go
there there's 66 apartments in my
building and you told them all not to go
yes it's toal
bit I wanted to turn around and smack
Eric in the mouth that's how that's how
angry it was he's behind us munching on
popcorn gry's face what was the food
like awful ready everything was pretty
horrible pretty horrible yeah they chewy
not too flavorful if you had the chance
to change what would it be better food
better food that is from the people on
the street and these people are going to
keep that place open my
God I was disgusted with the little
movie thing we just saw I don't believe
it's all that true you know it's not
that bad why do you find it funny we're
sat here in an embarrassing situation
there's definitely nothing to laugh
about Eric I don't know I don't I don't
believe all
it it infuriates me if the food was good
the save was excellent we have got to
start turning this
around can this restaurant Survivor Eric
run the
[Music]
kitchen I mean I have never experienced
anything like this in my
life okay there Paul yes sir I don't
know what's happened but the level of
frustration out there is intense so
stop we can't continue like this this
stop
it will you apologize the tables please
Rebecca what a freaking disaster bad I
know it was a terrible night we had
people not get food when tickets were
here we failed tonight it's my
responsibility sorry my friends the
kitchen has been shut down I'm so sorry
I've never had to do this
before never saw anything like that in
my life I understand that do you think
that I like this you think that I want
it to be like this I don't but but what
I'm one person with two hands Paul you
don't please don't start with excuses
that's not going to help Paul had a
horrible night 100% off his game and I
think gave up before he even got started
but people hated the food well that's
not what we got back here I very angry
saying that someone liked something 50
people didn't like it open your eyes I
have nothing else to say to
you equally as miserable as tonight's
dinner service was Paul's attitude and
Chef Ramsey wants to know why tonight
showed me that you hated cooking I
cannot ignite that little button I need
to say it from you Jeff I feel awful I
this is not the way that I want to work
or the way that I know that I can work
why are you doing it to yourself I
I
why you've got to give me the answer
because I can't start helping until you
tell me but I mean no one's asking you
to rent and Rave I'm just asking you to
have some fire
it's not normal for a guy that's been
cooking for 20 years plus to stand there
with no feel or passion and send
like that as if it's just going over
your head whether you like or not you
have given
[Music]
up your whole family is on the line here
do you know how hard it is to look at my
kids when I go home at
night or my
wife it's not easy
okay it's not supposed to be easy I
don't care if it's not easy I just want
it to be better but don't stop
[Music]
trying think I'm happy I'm miserable I
don't want to get out of bed in the
morning I want to stay in
[Music]
bed okay listen I'm committed to helping
you and I'm not leaving this place until
it's set we are going to work at this
together at turning this around tomorrow
I want you at your best yes yes get some
sleep thank you good night good
night I need to know that you're
committed committed to change cuz they
have no clue this restaurant turn around
cannot depend on them it depends on you
sticking with me is that clear
absolutely okay thank you now that Chef
Ramsey understands Brian's issues they
head back to the kitchen here I go
meanwhile bill is ready to serve the
tableside tsunami I get tired real quick
but to help the business I'll do
whatever I have to
do no it's me and rare if you just cut
that a little bit you'll see it's me and
rare all you have to do is cut it cut no
but I mean cut it this way cuz this was
sitting on a hot tile it's not medium a
okay I'm
sorry oh je they got a 70y old man going
around and around the dying room he
should be doing this at this pace I know
well they're too cuz they're too cheap
to hire anybody else what they're trying
to do put the father in the grave I mean
he's got one foot in there already he
didn't even want to do this he didn't
want he wanted to retire if that's what
hurts bill is
overworked and it's not
fair after a night where he witnessed a
dejected Chef unhappy patrons and an
overworked older owner Gordon knows he
has to have a serious talk with the
tough mother daughter team of Adele and
Cheryl I wanted to talk to you both
personally and express my concerns about
Bill I'm seriously worried about him in
a big way running around at the age of
70 pushing the cart why are you guys
letting him do this he really doesn't
work that
much you know what it's always poor
Bill that's Bill's
nickname poor Bill why have you asked me
to come here cuz I feel like I'm wasting
ing my time because we don't know what
the problem is the service downstairs
tonight how was that the kitchen
waster so you've employed the chef yeah
mhm and he hasn't been given chance to
cook he's cooking your menu right well I
we never changed the menu since we open
he never gets chance to show you what he
can cook because we felt that our food
was very good Christ are you
stupid
I guess I
am you're accepting that it's perfect
I'm trying to tell you bluntly that it's
not yet you never seem to accept your
own mistakes it's never you're doing we
thought our food was good but now you
just you know said it's horrible you
cannot see a problem in your own
establishment
no I'm being honest what I would like to
see is just a little bit more Integrity
with owning up to the responsibility to
why this place is not working there's no
acceptance on your own
mistakes good
night